Genomics is extending its reach into diverse
fields of biomedical research from agriculture
to clinical diagnostics.
Despite sharp falls in recent years, sequencing
costs remain substantial and vary for different
types of experiment.
Consequently, in all of these fields investigators
are seeking experimental designs that generate
robust scientific findings for the lowest
sequencing cost.
Higher coverage of sequencing inevitably requires
higher costs.
In next-generation sequencing studies, the
term “depth of coverage” refers to how
strong is a genome "covered" by sequenced
fragments (short reads)?
Per-base coverage is the average number of
times a base of a genome is sequenced.
The coverage depth of a genome is calculated
as the number of bases of all short reads
that match a genome divided by the length
of this genome.
It is often expressed as 1X, 2X, 3X,... (1,
2, or, 3 times coverage).
“Breadth of coverage” refers to how much
of a genome is "covered" by short reads?
Are there regions that are not covered, even
not by a single read?
Breadth of coverage is the percentage of bases
of a reference genome that are covered with
a certain depth.
For example, here is an example for whole
genome sequencing.
What coverage of a human genome will one get
with one lane of a HiSeq 2000 in paired-end
mode, if 200 million clusters were bound?
In this case, “paired-end” doubles the
read length because each fragment is sequenced
from both sides.
The number of sequenced bases can also be
computed by the number of reads x read length.
It should be noted that the computed average
is a theoretical unit.
Reads are not distributed evenly over an entire
genome.
That is an important fact especially for whole
genome sequencing.
Therefore, many bases will be covered by fewer
reads than the average coverage while other
bases will be covered by much more reads than
average.
Coverage histograms are commonly used to depict
the range and uniformity of sequencing coverage
for an entire data set.
They illustrate the overall coverage distribution
by displaying the number of reference bases
that are covered by mapped sequencing reads
at various depths.
Mapped read depth refers to the total number
of bases sequenced and aligned at a given
reference base position.
In a sequencing coverage histogram, the read
depths are binned and displayed on the x-axis,
while the total numbers of reference bases
that occupy each read depth bin are displayed
on the y-axis.
These can also be written as percentages of
reference bases.
Ideally, the plot will take the form of a
Poisson-like distribution with a small standard
deviation, as seen in the left-hand histogram
image.
This distribution is valid under the assumption
that reads are randomly distributed across
the genome and that the ability to detect
true overlaps between reads is constant within
a sequencing run.
However, for a variety of reasons, actual
coverage histograms may have a large spread,
or have a non-Poisson distribution, as seen
in the right-hand example of a poor sequencing
coverage histogram.
To evaluate the quality of the NGS coverage,
3 common metrics are usually used:
• Inter-Quartile Range (IQR)
The IQR is the difference in sequencing coverage
between the 75th and 25th percentiles of the
histogram.
This value is a measure of statistical variability,
reflecting the non-uniformity of coverage
across the entire data set.
A high IQR indicates high variation in coverage
across the genome, while a low IQR reflects
more uniform sequence coverage.
In the example histograms here, the lower
IQR indicates that the histogram on the left
has better sequencing coverage uniformity
than that on the right.
• Mean Read Depth
The mean read depth or mean mapped read depth
is the sum of the mapped read depths at each
reference base position, divided by the number
of known bases in the reference.
The mean read depth metric indicates how many
reads, on average, are likely to be aligned
at a given reference base position.
• Raw Read Depth
This is the total amount of sequence data
produced by the instrument during pre-alignment,
divided by the reference genome size.
Although raw read depth is often provided
by sequencing instrument vendors as a specification,
it does not take into account the efficiency
of the alignment process.
If a large fraction of the raw sequencing
reads are discarded during the alignment process,
the post-alignment mapped read depth can be
significantly smaller than the raw read depth.
An ideal genome sequencing method would faultlessly
read all nucleotides just once, doing so sequentially
from one end of a chromosome to the other.
Such a perfect approach would ensure that
all polymorphic alleles within diploid or
polyploid genomes could be identified, and
that long identical or near-identical repetitive
regions could be unambiguously placed in a
genome assembly.
In real-world sequencing approaches, read
lengths are short, often ≤250 nucleotides,
and can contain sequence errors.
When considered alone, an error is indistinguishable
from a sequence variant.
This problem can be overcome by increasing
the number of sequencing reads.
Even if reads contain a 1% variant-error rate,
the combination of eight identical reads that
cover the location of the variant will produce
a strongly supported variant call with an
associated error rate of 10−16.
Increased depth of coverage therefore 'rescues'
inadequacies in sequencing methods.
Nevertheless, generating greater depth of
short reads does not cure all sequencing ills.
In particular, it alone cannot resolve assembly
gaps that are caused by repetitive regions
with lengths that either approach or exceed
those of the reads.